- These are like right at the
size where you're not sure
if you should take a whole bite in one
or if you should bite it in half.
(upbeat music)
- Hello, good morning.
- Good morning, everyone, it's Mark Wiens
with Migrationology dot
com in Mumbai, India.
Good morning, Ying.
- Good morning.
- We have just checked out of our hotel
and we ordered an Uber
and we're on our way
to the airport.
But our flight is not
out until later tonight,
as we're gonna go to the
airport, we're gonna try
to check in our bag and
then we're gonna go to
the Juhu Beach area in
Mumbai and hopefully
hang out around that area for the day
before we go back to the airport.
(upbeat music)
We just made it to the airport.
So now we're gonna see
where we can leave our bag
for the rest of the day.
The baggage storage facility
is in the parking lot
of the arrivals area and
our baggage is stored
for the next six hours.
- Hello.
- [Mark] Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Mark] Okay, have a great day.
- Yeah.
- That all went remarkably
smooth and hassle-free.
We are now in a mini-minivan
and on our way to go eat.
(upbeat music)
The taxi just dropped us off very near
to Mithibai College, and
we're just going to walk down
the road a little bit
to a street food stall
that is famous for serving dosa.
Can I have the paneer tikka dosa?
(speaking in foreign language)
Thank you.
This place is called Anand Stall
and they are famous, especially
for sandwiches and dosas
and I did not want to leave India
without having a good dosa.
I ordered the paneer tikka
dosa and then they give you
a little token, you pay at the front there
and then you go over
here to the dosa counter
to pick it up.
I will never get bored of
watching someone make food
on the street.
(light music)
(indistinct chatter)
In order to make this
kind of modern version
of a dosa, what he did
was he first spread out
the batter onto the hot
platter and he cooked
the batter and then he added in the cubes
of paneer cheese and
then he added in a bunch
of different sauces, that
tikka sauce, some chili,
he sprinkled on some
seasoning, he added in
a handful of dhania which is cilantro
and then I thought they were
actually going to keep it all
wrapped up inside the dosa but actually
they scooped it onto a big
plate and then they served
the dosa, they wrapped it
up and served it on the side
along with some chutney.
Oh, and it's crispy and
soft at the same time.
And go in for all of that beautiful,
it's almost, yeah, it's
prepared kind of like a curry.
But I love how they're
so many greens in there.
I think there's green
onions in there as well.
Oh, look at that.
That looks incredible.
Wow!
That is incredible.
It's just packed full of flavor.
You've got the crispy sort of like spongy
but very thin, like almost
like crepe like dosa.
And then that curry.
I cannot believe how
quickly and how masterfully
he whipped up that paneer tikka.
I was expecting it to be
good, but that is incredible.
And then I will add some
extra chutney to it.
I think this is a coconut based chutney.
Oh that chutney, oh yeah.
It is coconut based.
And then I can really taste
the curry leaf in there
as well as I think some coriander
and some cumin in there, maybe.
Some people order and then
just stand around and eat.
But other people get their
plate and they go sit
in their car or they
go stand somewhere down
the sidewalk and eat.
You can eat anywhere around here you like.
What really makes a difference for me
is the, all of that,
those chopped up herbs
within the curry and then
of course the chutney.
It kind of has a nutty taste to it, too.
Almost like cashew tasting
in the curry as well.
That was literally just
everything I could possibly want
in a dosa.
(upbeat music)
And we are on our way to Juhu Beach.
Thank you.
It is really, really windy.
Check out Ying's hair.
(laughs)
Hello.
How are you?
Nice to meet you.
And I already have a new friend.
What is your name?
(indistinct)
(light music)
It's so windy, so I don't
know if you're gonna be able
to hear me on the
microphone, I hope you can,
but we came to the beach,
there is so much going on again
and I'm sure it's not nearly
as busy as it gets later on
in the day, but lots of people here,
lots of action going on,
people are flying kites,
there are, it's just a colorful display
of people and clothes and things for sale.
And I came to the beach so
I had to order a coconut.
Few things are greater
at refreshing oneself
than a fresh coconut.
Oh, coconut water is delicious.
It started raining
pretty hard so we came in
to the, like food court, hawker
stall, street food section
and there's just a ton of food in here.
Walking around now, lots
and lots of different chaats
and snacks to eat, I just
gotta find the right place
to eat now.
(light music)
There is a torrential downpour right now
and the wind is just
whipping through this alley
of food stalls.
And actually it feels really
good because it's so cool
but it is kind of a chaotic environment
and pao bhaji is one of the
ultimate Mumbai street food
snacks available everywhere.
This will be my first time
to try it in Mumbai so far,
I haven't had a chance
yet but I'm glad it,
you can actually just smell
the pao bhaji being cooked
within these stalls within the alleys.
And I hope you can hear
me over that music.
So in order to make the pao phaji,
what they do is they take
tomatoes and potatoes
and a bunch of different
spices and then they cook it
on a huge giant round hot skillet
and it just slowly cooks
and they slowly like mash
it down with all the spices.
They mix it with butter,
and then they just sort of
store it on the side of the
hot plate throughout the day
and then when it's ordered
they grab some of it
and stick it into the
middle of the hot plate
and mix it with water, I think,
and then make it into a kind of a sauce
and then add lots of butter again,
and then they take bread and
add some butter to the bread
of course and then fry it on the hot plate
to crispify it, and
then they serve it here
and this is, you know,
it's the combination
of pao, which is a bun like
this, and then the bhaji,
which is this tomato,
potato puree with spices.
Mm.
You can feel the starchiness of the potato
but then it has a really
nice like tartness
from the tomato and then
it's a little bit spicy, you can taste
that blend of cumin and
turmeric in there as well.
And then yeah, you can
taste the butter in there
quite well as well.
I'm gonna take a piece of the bread next.
Probably mix in with some of the onions.
Oh, and that little blob of butter
on the top there as well.
Mm.
That's a very buttery, fluffy roll.
And then I really like it with the onions
because they're crisp and
they give it that extra
onion taste, onions never hurt anything.
I can see why this is so attractive.
It is a nice combination.
(speaking in foreign language)
Thank you.
Bombay bhelpuri.
- Bombay bhelpuri.
- Okay.
The next snack I wanted to
try here is mumbai bhelpuri.
And this is a snack mixture.
There are, I think it's puffy rice
with a bunch of different crunchy things
and he really stirred it up in a chutney
and then he mixed it with,
there is some cilantro,
some dhania, and then also
some other little crispies
in here, and this is another, like,
just like a mixture of
different crispies and chutneys.
They stuck a couple spoons in it.
Oh yeah, and also there's lots
of onions in here as well.
And you can see, I think these
are all little rice crispies
and little crunchy bits.
Mm!
- [Man] Chili sauce?
- Okay, yes.
Chili sauce, chili sauce.
On the side.
(speaking in foreign language)
Thank you.
Oh, he just added on
some extra chili sauce
and some onions.
And then for this one,
I'm gonna take the lime.
And squeeze it all over.
It's kind of sweet and savory and crispy.
Yeah, it tastes like
rice crispies, just mixed
with all sorts of sweet and
tangy and spicy and onions.
Oh, and there's some potatoes in there,
on the bottom there too, I think.
Mm, oh yeah, with that hit,
with that squeeze of lime.
That's nice because it contrasts
that sweet, tangy sauce.
These little spoons are kind of flimsy.
Mm.
This is a good beach snack.
So I would really recommend
that you try pao bhaji
when you come to Juhu,
there are many, many places
to eat pao bhaji and there
are lots and lots of food.
The bhelpuri was awesome and the stall
and the owner there was really nice.
(light music)
We are heading to go try and
find one more last chaat,
one snack before we head
back to the airport.
This will be the final, final snack.
I gotta hope it's open.
(light music)
Okay, thank you.
Luckily the stall is open,
so one more last chaat
before we go the airport.
(speaking in foreign language)
Can I have sev puri?
- Sev puri?
Yeah, sure, sure.
- [Mark] Thank you.
(speaking in foreign language)
Yes.
- [Man] So you are here
for, travel or something?
- [Mark] Yes, travel to eat.
- [Man] Travel to eat?
(laughs)
(speaking in foreign language)
- This stall is located on
the corner of Sixth Street,
which is in the neighborhood
just kind of back
from Juhu Beach, and it's actually right,
just kind of in the
neighborhood from where we
ate that dosa a couple hours ago.
But I'm so glad they're
open, I really wanted to try
their sev puri before leaving Mumbai.
It's topped with so many ingredients
but under here there are little discs.
And what he does, crispy discs.
And what he does is he takes the discs,
puts on some potatoes and some onions
and a bunch of different
chutneys and then sprinkles it
with all these crispies and then,
what are these things?
I'm not totally sure and
then some dhania cilantro,
and chili, and so it's like a little disc
of many toppings and if
I take out the first one
hopefully we can all see what is inside.
Oh, yeah.
The cross section.
There are onions in there and potatoes.
Mm!
Oh, this is one of my favorite chaats.
That potato is so creamy
that it almost reminds me
of guacamole, it's like avocado almost.
You got a little bit of spice going on,
it burns your throat a
little bit going down,
and then you can taste the sweetness
from the chutney, it's so well balanced
and that is an awesome snack.
It's like crunchy and juicy.
I wanna taste on of these little things.
I'm not totally sure what that, this is.
Mm!
I think that's mango.
Mm.
Nice and sour and crisp.
These are right at that size
where they are almost too
big to take a full bite
but then at the same time you're not sure
if you want to bite it in
half and risk collapsing
the entire, the entire snack bite.
I'll go with the one bite.
Those chutneys.
And then everything just
collapses in your mouth.
Okay, thank you.
- International, domestic?
- International.
Terminal two.
- Huh?
- Terminal two.
- Oh, oh.
- Okay, thank you.
No, it is a microphone.
- Oh.
- Do you see for wind, for audio.
- Ah, my photo.
- Yes.
What is your name?
- Hami Nash.
- Hami Nash, nice to meet you.
I am so glad that we got
to stop at that chaat stall
for our last bite to eat in Mumbai.
That was stunning.
That's one of my favorite
chaats, sev puri,
and that was a great, great version of it.
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, sev puri is so good.
We're not racing to catch our flight,
but we are sort of racing
back to the airport
because I want to avoid
paying the next level fee
for our baggage storage.
So we're hoping to get back in time
to grab our bags.
(light music)
Our driver just stopped and got out
to use the restroom.
So I'm hoping we'll still make it.
Okay, for you.
- [Ying] Thank you.
- Thank you, okay.
Have a nice day, nice day.
There's nothing quite like rolling up to
an international airport
in an auto rickshaw.
We made it back to the luggage stand
with literally three minutes to spare.
If our auto rickshaw driver
had spent three more minutes
in the bathroom during his bathroom break
in the middle of our ride, we
would have missed that level
and had to pay extra for
our bag at the baggage drop.
No, he was, he was a really fun driver.
He was a really nice guy.
(light music)
We got all checked into the airport
and went through
immigration and we are now
sitting at the Air India lounge.
We have about three hours
until our flight even boards.
But I wanted to come
here early just to relax
in the lounge and also I
have a lot of work to do
so I'm gonna sit here and
well, actually I'll probably go
eat right now and see
what they have for food.
(light music)
I'm gonna need a couple of cups of coffee.
And I sort of went with half salad,
Mediterranean food and half Indian food.
I love chili paneer, so I had
to go for some chili paneer.
Mm.
Yeah.
Chili paneer's one of the great dishes.
I've definitely had a lack of salad
in the last few days, so
I'm ready to eat some salad.
I got some email done
and I could not resist
going for another plate of food.
They brought out some new
dishes and I got mostly salad
but I could not resist a
piece of lamb rogan josh,
which is an amazing dish.
Oh, that's like a big chunk of something.
Oh, look how tender that lamb is.
I'm gonna have to go back
and get some more of that.
Oh, that's amazing.
Tender lamb.
Tomatoey, just wonderful sauce.
Oh, that's good.
It has been an amazing trip to Mumbai
and it's only been four
days but it's been a pretty
action-packed four days
and I think we managed
to do quite a bit and eat some
incredibly delicious food.
A special thank you to all of
you for your recommendations
for all the food to eat in Mumbai.
(light music)
(indistinct)
Thank you very much.
Ying is pretending to be asleep.
And this is going to be
about a three hour ride,
flight to Muscat, Oman.
(light music)
Dinner on the flight is served.
I went for the angara murgh masala.
Oh, and there's a chili on top here.
How wonderful for that chicken masala.
You can taste the blend of masala spices,
it's buttery, it's nutty, and it's creamy.
Take a bite of the dahl.
(upbeat music)
- [Loudspeaker] Passengers,
return our request
to kindly remain seated.
And we'll be--
- Thank you.
Okay, we just landed in Muscat.
It is 11:30 PM at night and
they said it's 39 degrees.
Oh, you can feel that oven heat.
Thank you, Air India, for the good flight.
And Star Alliance.
We're just now waiting for our bag
and then we're gonna
catch a taxi to our hotel.
City Seasons Hotel.
- Okay, City Seasons Hotel?
- Hotel, yes.
City Seasons Hotel.
- Ah, City Seasons Hotel.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)
Hi, good evening.
- [Man] Hello.
- Taxi was pretty expensive.
We are definitely in a
different country now.
Just a very quick tour of the room,
this is the bathroom, nice and spacious.
And then this is the main room here.
Blue and desert themed.
I'm excited to be in Muscat, Oman.
This is my very first trip visit to Oman,
but I'm about to go to sleep now,
it's been a long day, I'm pretty tired.
So I'm gonna end the video for today now,
thank you all for watching.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it
and also leave a comment below
and make sure you subscribe for lots more
food and travel videos and I
will see you on the next video
for our first full day in Muscat, Oman.
(beep)
I think that's a big chunk of cauliflower.
Oh.
Oh, tomato just went flying under my lap.
That's why, that's why they have napkins.
(chuckles)
(light music)